hallo leute ich es wieder eure mal waren
und willkommen zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt und heute machen wir endlich
die krosse krabbe pizza ist die pc
shooter chris perry aus meiner
lieblingsserie spongebob schwammkopf und
zwar kommt sie deine ersten staffel in
der fünften folge vor und krosse krabbe
macht gerade feierabend als ein anruf
reinkommt eine pizzabestellung und wir
wissen ja alle wie geld geister crepes
ist und der will natürlich pizza
verkaufen obwohl es keine pizza gibt
also was macht mister crepes er nimmt
einen teller voll mit krapfen bürgern
box drei mal drauf und schon ist es eine
pizza logisch und ich möchte heute zum
einen mister krebs variante ausprobieren
und eine eigene kleine krosse krabbe
pizza variation machen
also bleibt gespann cosgrove bild sah
auch euch ja auch eigentlich nicht mehr
viel erzählen über spongebob mehr meine
lieblingsserie schon immer gewesen ich
weiß als ich damals ein räuber hat es
glaub ich angefangen mir leider habe es
nicht verstanden die waren immer total
schockiert verliefen schwamm und ich
habe es geliebt falls ihr noch nicht
weiß wie man krabben bürger macht ich
verlinke euch mal das bunte kramberger
video unten in der infobox da könnt ihr
mal drauf klicken da hab ich nämlich
schon mal krabben bürger gemacht und
ansonsten mache ich sie jetzt einfach
noch mal ich werde aber nicht so genau
erklären wie gesagt wenn ihr nicht wisst
wie gramm bürger gehen infobox damit
alles vorgeschnitten man braucht als
erstes ein brötchen boden dann kommt die
bulette dazu zur box zu probieren
ich liebe fleischersatz fleischersatz
schmeckt richtig geil da einfach noch
eine scheibe salat umbau gefolgt von der
scheibe käse jetzt kommen die zwiebeln
drauf
eine fliegende zwiebel schaut her meine
damen und herren ich habe eine fliegende
zwiebel tomaten richtig tumblr hier mein
burger ketchup und senf und wenn ihr das
wirklich ein glas auf kriegt dann kommt
eigentlich noch brötchen darauf hört und
als krönender abschluss noch ein
brötchen darf ich mache jetzt einfach
mal ein paar und dann sehen uns richtig
was soll der geiz wir probieren mal das
ist wirklich lecker eine sache möchte
ich mal ausprobieren die band schon mal
gemacht hat man durch krieg gar nicht
das sind jetzt unser krabben burger und
die müssen jetzt in den mixer in den
mixer sie da überhaupt die passen da
doch gar nicht geht muss sie halbieren
sagt tschüss zum krabbeln burger main
sind die ganzen herzlichst muss ich mich
immer noch in bitteschön perrys musik
wie das aussieht haben auch sie keine
zeit mit etwas zu essen hier machen sie
sich einen burger smoothie in der tag
ist gerettet
okay wir brauchen definitiv ein bisschen
flüssigkeit öl oder wasser öl oder
wasser öl oder was in den beides ein
bisschen
doch ist so richtig schön feucht so wie
wir unseren bürger mögen kann ich mal so
scheiße und so sehen also bürger aus
wenn ihr sie durch den mixer gejagt hat
und daraus machen wir jetzt einen teig
du bist ein hype ich bin kein koks meliá
als würdest du dich trauen teig hahaha
heikler blabla heikel eine frau niveau
ok also was tut man wenn man das vorher
matsche pampe einen teig hinkriegen
möchte genau dann macht ein bisschen
mehr als die habe
ein bisschen mehl und ein bisschen hilfe
rein damit dass ein bisschen fluffig
wird der teig ich meine es ist eine
krosse krabbe pizza und sie ist aus
geraden bürger gemacht
jetzt sehen wir ein bisschen von dieser
hilfe lösen ist ein bisschen wasser auf
und kippen es dazu dann wird hoffentlich
ein guter teil ganz die hälfte mit dem
lauwarmen wasser als verrührt man jetzt
schön und da stecke ich jetzt meine hand
meine haare sind knethaken echt gespannt
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass es redet
gut schmecken wird das ist ein kinder
das recht hat wirklich nach bürger du
riechst die glöckchen die tomaten wegen
der hefe die rein gemacht haben lassen
jetzt ein bisschen ausruhen ein bisschen
fluffig werden und in der zeit freue
mich auf das ist ja hier kein apple
marmelade mit honig nur dass ein
bisschen aufwendiger und bisschen glück
jetzt wieder sauber und unser teig ist
groß geworden ist aber groß geworden
mensch joachim behm ist mir jetzt
natürlich und so machen sie doch die
italiener oder hier das ist unser teich
und da müssen wir dem land einmal so
hoch rollen weil das der großen kampf
und pizza auch sonst wer hat zur
abwechslung wieder schön damals gelingen
würden ähnlich wie die kids sind auf
euch warten muss die rote beete kekse
waren jetzt nicht so schlecht oder ich
meinen hat jemand von euch nach gemacht
nein sehr gut könnt ihr euch vorstellen
dass das vor ein paar minuten noch
bürger waren ohne wird es sind einfach
pürierte burger mit ein bisschen mehl
und lief wenn man sieht auf der pizza
dass da halt käse drauf ist salami und
champignons champignons habe ich jetzt
nicht besorgt aber ich habe
vegetarische mensa lan wohnt käse ich
weiß nicht genau was der krebs noch die
zutaten her hatte denn er hat der nur
mit einer faust auf die krabben burger
gehauen aber da fragen wir jetzt mal
nicht richtig nach es ist alles eine
frage der fantasie
schritt nummer eins wir machen ein
bisschen käse drauf jetzt haben wir hier
käse drauf und jetzt kommt noch salami
und jetzt kommen wieder die leute die
fleisch essen sagen
aber warum ist du dann die vegetarische
salami wenn du keine echte behrami ist
es geht um die tierhaltung leute wenn du
dir als vegetarier ein vegetarisches
schnitzel holst dann magst du eigentlich
schnitzel und findest fleisch auch
lecker aber du unterstützt nicht die
tierhaltung denn die ist heiße und das
ist sie unsere krosse krabbe pizza und
jetzt kommt sie in den ofen
ich bin wirklich sehr gespannt offenen
wird ich bin so gespannt ich habe
nämlich das gefühl dass sie super lecker
sein kann aber es werden wir gleich
während unsere erste version jetzt
gerade im ofen ist probieren wir noch
eine zweite aus und zwar habe ich dafür
einen pizzateig vorbereitet einen ganz
normalen mit mehl hefe olivenöl salz und
ein bisschen wasser in einerseits habe
ich bei der kosten kraft pizza an diese
zermatschten kramberger gedacht und dass
man daraus noch witze macht und
andererseits könnte man ja auch eine
pfütze machen und sie mit klammen bürger
zutaten belegen was nennt man statt
einer tomatensoße auf der großen graben
pizza natürlich catcher es gibt ja schon
so was wie die hot dog pizza bei joeys
glaube ich aber eine burger pizza habe
ich noch nie gesehen und die basics
nicht mal so was wie ein burger pizza
bip tatort an lima gemacht statt einer
bulette nehmen ihr vegetarisches hack
dass krümmel wird also um drauf wir
brauchen auf jeden fall auch noch mit
zwiebel und nicht den finger schneiden
nicht weil ich merkte wie aufgeregt ich
bin jetzt müssen dennoch gewürzgurken
[Musik]
senf tomaten haben wir etwas es denn
noch offen
als krönender abschluss kommt jetzt noch
ein bisschen käse und auf den salat
mache ich drauf wenn die pizza wieder
aus dem open ist weil der würde einfach
nutzer matschen lediglich werden
deswegen lacht oh mein gott sie schön
geworden
man auch gleich mal die andere doch
hinten rein ja jetzt wird mir warm wie
kostet kraft pizza ist die pizza pizza
also fürs aussehen kriegt definitiven
einsplus weil die sieht so aus wie die
krosse krabbe pizza jetzt stellen wir
uns natürlich weder den allerwichtigsten
frage wie schmeckt die krosse krabbe
pizza schmeckt der teig ist richtig gut
geworden
oh ja und wenn ihr mir nicht glaubt dass
sie wirklich gut schmeckt dann kommt
jetzt heißt es dann aber zu hoch die
geige schmeckt so geil und hier ist sie
pizza nummer 28 der salat fehlt noch
jetzt stellen wir uns natürlich wieder
der allerwichtigsten frage wie schmeckt
pizza nummer zwei ist halt ne pizza wie
nach burgers schmeckt kommt nicht drauf
klaas nichts zu lecker ich werde langsam
zum profi also gibt mir eine größere
challenge sehr gute sachen wie immer
hoffe ich natürlich ist euch die folge
gefeiert und wenn ja dann zeigt das nur
mit einem daumen nach oben und wenn ihr
noch mehr rezeptvorschläge habt aus film
und serien was danach kommen soll
rein in die kommentare ich sehe jetzt
meine pizza und ihr könnt euch andere
wie schmeckt zeugen angucken
die andere vergessen
spaß ich habe nach dem bürger vergessen
die krosse krabbe pizza